white supremacy white supremacy white
supremacy they think if they say it
enough they'll get a pat on the back
from black lives matter everything is
white supremacy
when you have the kind of voter
suppression that we've seen all across
the country which is really just about
white supremacy
all of them the whole time totally
irresponsible in flaming racial tensions
to push a political agenda
is the new republican america first
caucus just a fancied up name for white
supremacy
i don't know brian williams is it is it
anything that you don't like that's
white supremacy now just like anything
you don't agree with is misinformation
the destructive divisive grift of these
white allies of the woke left these race
hustlers is tearing our country apart
and if they had the slightest decency or
sense of moral responsibility they'd
stand up to the activists and extremists
on their own side but they won't because
they're cowards
joining me now with reaction the
co-founder of speak georgia conservative
commentator janelle king and political
analyst malik abdul jannel it's just
been so
infuriating to watch these people who
claim to be about racial justice using
all this using these trials to inflame
racial division and tensions exactly the
opposite of what we should be seeing
happen in this country
yes absolutely and this case wasn't
about racial justice it was about
justice period and justice for everyone
but the interesting thing is that i have
watched the democratic party use the
weapon of racism to try to move masses
of people over and over and over again
and it's just sinister in the very sense
of the word because you take the most
hurtful part of our of our country's
past and you continue to bring it up
over and over and over again at moments
when it's not even justified in order to
try to manipulate the masses and this
case was no exception at all this case
had nothing to do with race nothing to
do with racism it was simply a young boy
who was in a situation where he defended
himself and that's just it if it wasn't
for the fact that the narrative
outweighed or or
the narrative was able to drive the
whole story before the trial even
started we wouldn't be talking about
this and that is our issue and that is
the main problem is that we allow the
narrative to be created and formed by
these rape hustlers and gatekeepers
rather than sitting and waiting for
facts and listening to the actual
situation and what happened
exactly so well put janelle um malik you
know you could you know the the the
sinister aspect of what um what we saw
much and i was talking about there was
so highlighted by the way that you know
these trials you know with with written
house oh that was the wrong reaction the
wrong result because it didn't fit the
narrative but in the georgia case just
this past week oh well that's the right
result obviously it's not about justice
about their narrative
yeah so
what with the democratic party and the
media at large they're really afraid of
people like me you know someone who left
the democratic party in 2016 and
supported donald trump in large part
because i was tired of this game that
democrats play all the time you played
an entire montage of what i actually
called the for-profit race hustling
industry and it wasn't just the people
our liberal white friends who were
actually out there doing that if you
listen to the the actual president of
the naacp
he compared the written house trial to
the emmett till trial and said that the
emmett till trial was actually worse
than the written house trial this is
what the for-profit race industry does
and we know the horrors of our country
yes we are dealing now with the vestiges
of racism but the thing is is that we
have come so far and what the democratic
party and the people on the left and the
media narrative they want to keep this
narrative of victor and victim and
that's where they want to keep black
people at the bottom end of that scale
to make us constantly feel that we are
in a state of oppression against the
evil white man who's around the corner
ready to just do us some dirty justice
and keep in mind it isn't just our white
um this isn't just white people this is
actually reserved for white
conservatives not their white liberal
friends like joe biden who goes around
telling black people that unless you
support him then you ain't black that's
what the democratic party is and we're
tired of it it is disgusting
it's so amazing you just said because i
was literally about to take almost word
for word how you ended there and put it
straight over to janelle and say you
come on fox news and you say what you do
and that's what they accuse you of right
oh absolutely you know like malik said
we are the biggest threat to the
democratic party because we can't be
told lies and all these stories around
our community and our communi and what
our community has gone through we know
and the thing about it is at the end of
the day we have to remember that the
left is a group of people who claim that
they're fighting for justice for all but
it's not justice for all it's justice
for those who believe like them and
those who act like them because whenever
if you want to say justice for all we
don't have to march for that we don't
have to fight that we have to riot for
that you know why because we already
have it it's called the constitution and
it allows equal rights for each and
every one of us and that is what we all
can get behind as americans
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else